[Music]
hello and welcome to this video which is
part 5 chapter 5 of our fight before
Lackawanna series and this is the first
chapter that deals with the Petrov
I mean we had this move order on the
board already a four other earlier
chapters but here with the move deform
we're going to examine one move that
really keeps the game within the Petrov
boundaries we've looked at other moves
Knight c3 for example in Chapter three
and four but White's most principle
tries against a Petrov always have been
Knight takes e5 it will be subject of
the final three chapters what D form
which we will look at in this chapter
chapter five and in Chapter six in
Chapter six just to be clear what what
what is the separation there in Chapter
six we will look at just one particular
line the old main line of the system
which runs like this I just want to get
this out of the way this is what we're
looking at this move we've been looking
at in chapter 6 and chapter 5 in this
video and in this chapter of the course
we will look at everything that might
happen before this position arises after
six moves because here after the six six
moves there's quite a body of theorem
that will be looked at in the next video
and in the next chapter so back to the
starting position
yeah D form is one of White's principles
tries and it is the second main line
that say after Knight takes e5 the move
D form has been featured in in the
kiwanis games and it has been featured
in key games also of the candidates
tournament in 2018 where Kawana
qualified to get to the match again
magnus carlsen we see some of these
examples yeah in the next yeah two hours
problem I think it will be roughly to
our video
okay deform what is some black going to
do against this move there is in fact
only one satisfactory move and this is
the one I'm going to recommend this is
to capture only form the alternatives
are really not great you have he takes
d4 that has been tried in high-level
games but these are all like 20 30 years
old
it is now established that white is
better after you 5 you also King all d6
but that is a bad version of a
philidor's all of that is not great if
we have to check on e4 and this is also
according to the general principle that
we should take the center pawn on reform
if we can do so unpunished so it's nice
to follow a general concept so what is
white doing now here white may move by a
mile is the move Bishop d3 to attack the
knight that is what they're almost all
of them playing but it's not the only
move and there is one move in particular
that is interesting to check when we get
to that that this D takes e5 can put it
on the board there are two rare moves
here that are worth checking but that is
quickly dealt with white could also take
on e5 and now black has an interesting
choice you can play the move d5 for a
complete symmetry which very likely
after Bishop d3 97 were transposed to
the main line of this complex or and
this is my suggestion because that is a
bit more straightforward but there is no
difference in quality really d6 to
attack the knight white will retreat and
after d5 oops
that shouldn't happen I hope that is not
happening again added in an earlier
video but with a weird software glitch
anyway here we transposed to
the main line with 90/65 on move three
it's a pretty funny transposition yeah
so that is the same position after after
this okay let's go back let's go back
before 95d success one thing I need to
mention white could do this one which is
a little bit irritating at first maybe
because King takes f7 Queen h5 is
actually good for white but you have
queenie 7 this is an important motif to
remember now we are taking indirectly
the King unfriending Knight c3 check
winning the Queen and that means we are
winning in the house him winning the
night at least so this does not work
it's it's funny by the way that this
position was featured in a game between
smearin and Anand and a record game
where Anand when a blitz game actually
Rihanna not took I think more than one
and a half minute for his move he was
deeply irritated it seems with 90 85 by
95 we can still find that on YouTube
it's a funny video also because of the
commentary anyway
let's go back in 95 is purely
transpositional or bad for white and
sometimes why just try to Queen eat you
but that is probably a case where white
confused lines somewhere because that
means it's not really great we can just
go d5 and ask white what the Queen is
doing only two after Knight takes e5
Bishop e7 for example we are going to
Castle short next rupee eight and
somehow there's a queen only two that
doesn't belong so this is completely
completely uncritical going back here
the only real alternative to Bishop d3
which again is by far the most popular
move the only real alternative is to
take on e5 and this is a move that in
fact has gained quite a bit of
popularity in recent years the main
reason for that is not because it is
particularly fantastic but the reason is
that the other lines the traditional
lines that have been played yes in since
ages they are all completely fine for
black and in some cases there's really
not much more that white can try
this settled that in many of those lines
it is just okay so white has tried a new
yeah new ways and D takes d5 is such a
such an idea my suggestion is to play d5
if that is the most natural move it
needs to be mentioned and that this move
exists and leads to very sharp
complications after Bishop c4 this is
however extremely tough to learn I think
it's purely technical and very very
difficult to remember and ultimately I
decided to recommend d5 this is also
what Khurana has played in this position
all of the time and very successfully we
have to have to add so let's go d5 a
normal-looking strong move we have taken
only form on the on the third move and
we have played d5 two things that I keep
mentioning during this series that
whenever black men manages that getting
rid of the e pawn playing d5 that is
usually okay and this is definitely no
exception if you just look at this on
general grounds we have a good foothold
in the center and the bishops can be
developed is it this is a common
scenario in the petrov you don't have a
bad piece that's very important you can
develop freedom so what is White's idea
with this whole line he tries to
establish this pawn on e5 and with this
pawn on e5 yeah enjoying a little bit of
a space advantage in controlling these
two squares in particulars as White's
try what are White's argument in favor
of his position
what black has we have a four against
three here we are four points again
three majority on that side of the board
and quite often with c5 we can set this
in motion here white most often goes for
Knight BD - I need to mention that there
is Bishop d3 and this is also very
decent move but this we will look at why
a different
on this we will look at by a bishop D 3
D 5 D 6 D 5 because that is the far more
frequent yeah in order to reach this
position but technically speaking it is
the same position and it is a decent
move for white moves that are not scary
include eat XD 6 on a song it's just
important that you play Bishop takes d6
I'm not really sure why but there are
games in the database where black played
Knight takes c6 and that makes no sense
why would you decentralize your strong
piece if you enjoyed the free video
preview make sure to go to
chesterlaw.com slash fight like a
Khurana to get to the full course the
full course with the move trainer and
video sync technology is an excellent
way to learn all the ideas and
strategies connected to this repertoire
these lines were essential in kiwanis
fight to get the world title match and
they can be an essential part of your
opening repertoire as well
[Music]